[Musique]
la civilisation antique avait engendré
le centaure l'homme cheval notre
civilisation de chevaux vapeur est enfin
d'engendrer une autre créature moitié
homme moitié au taux le buste humain est
appelée à rester rivé à son corps
mécanique en toutes circonstances
l'amérique toujours en avance de dix ans
a vu naître la créature le monde s'est
mis à sa portée et la moto puisqu'il
faut bien l'appeler ainsi que désormais
régler ces opérations bancaires sans
bouger du volant la femme auto
contrôlant toujours l'emploi des fonds
la faim fait ralentir le moto dont la
vitesse est normalement de 150
kilomètres à l'heure alors il s'adresse
un microphone interlocuteur valable
puisque immédiatement
voici que se dirige vers lui le menu
comment des organisations admirable qui
permettrait à la moto français s'ils en
étaient déjà là d'acheter le billet de
la tranche spéciale du prochain prix de
l'arc de triomphe
entre lille et bordeaux sans quitter son
volant un gros lot de 2 millions de
francs ne se laisse pas passer même à
150 à l'heure au prix d'un petit
exercice qui disons le implique un
minimum d'intimité avec son voisin
immédiat la moto peut songer à faire des
tâches et ses vêtements sans risquer de
perdre un temps précieux à la station
tout a été prévu même une hôtesse dans
une tenue destinée à enlever tout
complexe aux clients
[Musique]
au volant la moto ne risquent même pas
de manquer le service religieux
les cavaliers du moyen-âge pénétrait à
cheval dans les cathédrales lui suit la
cérémonie au parking
m
l'homme au temple décidément vivre sans
jamais quitter sa voiture
[Musique]
sauf dans un cas un seul mais faisons
confiance au progrès
[Musique]